[Music]
caitlyn joins us up next she's in
arizona caitlyn welcome to the show
hello how are you good how can we help
today
yeah i just had a quick question in
regards to overcoming a negative mindset
so i'm 29 i live out in arizona i'm a
single mom and as you know our
housing market has been
so intense to say the least
um and i'm paying about 60 of my
take-home pay and rent wow
i
yeah i can't buy in this market i don't
make enough i pulled down to about 40
last year um and i just feel like i'm
spinning my wheels and that treading
water feeling is really starting to get
to me so i was hoping you could provide
some insight on that if possible
yeah i mean i'll be honest caitlin i'm
like i i would feel that too if if more
than half the paycheck is going to
housing that's uh that's a big chunk so
tell me
um a little bit more about kind of the
situation because you
are obviously in a
more expensive i don't know if it's an
area or apartment or what it is is there
other options for you to to change
locations just to at least
catch your breath and bring it down to
at least you know we recommend 25 30 but
even if went down to 35 that would
change your world
right yeah i live in a two-bedroom
apartment right now um and i pay about
2000 a month i had looked at going down
to a one-bedroom the only trouble with
that it was it would only save me maybe
300 bucks a month but i actually work
from home um so i need and i have my son
here with me too so i don't know how we
would make that work yeah no two
bedrooms yeah yeah
yeah so have you read i haven't
i'm sorry i was going to just say have
you have you driven you know 20 miles
either direction of where you currently
are just to see other prices
uh right now i'm already kind of on the
edge of
what i would consider to be a safe area
so i i can look maybe a little bit
deeper into phoenix but i just want to
make sure
we're still safe and everything's good
like that so um i could i mean i i work
remotely so i could probably buy in
other states and other markets but my
son's father's here and i really just
don't want to leave my home state so for
sure
and how much do you make a year
i pulled down about 40 uh last year okay
what are you doing for work
i work at a call center for an insurance
company okay
so there's there's only two ways we can
go about this and we can we can spend
less and we can make more so do you have
any payments in your life that we can
get rid of do you have any debt
i don't have any debt um i do have that
going for me i don't have any debt and i
do
anticipate my income going up i actually
i had a conversation yesterday with my
supervisor that made me feel like maybe
something close is on the horizon um for
getting my my pay up um i think it's
just this waiting period between
making more money and trying to find
something cheaper to rent it's just it's
mentally been draining me i think but um
well especially as a single mom i mean
you're you got your how old your held
your son
he just turned six his name's mason i
think he might be listening that's
awesome
that's awesome oh you're doing an
incredible job caitlyn i mean you know
the the hard thing is it's nothing that
you're doing wrong it's just that the
numbers are kind of stacked against you
and so
like george said you know an option of
bringing in more i mean right now the
job market is just
insane and so i would push and look to
see if you can even i mean 40 grand you
know you're you're you're doing fine
but man people are paying just insane
amounts of money right now for jobs and
and since yours is not like very
specifically specialized you know what i
mean like i feel like you could um do
all sorts of things uh even with the
experience that you've had in this
insurance role
um so you know i don't know if it's
looking for something else or a
different apartment but one of those two
things really probably it needs to shift
for your own sanity kaitlyn you know
what i mean like temporarily yeah to
have the numbers work for you um
is going to be a big deal do you have an
emergency fund kaitlyn
i do yeah okay three to six months in
there
i still have my baby one
i have a one thousand dollar emergency
fund and then i have about four thousand
in my my actual emergency fund so i
still need to build that up okay i think
building that up may help with a little
bit of that financial peace and anxiety
about what if something happens if one
check doesn't come in what are we gonna
do and if you get that in place then i'm
gonna start saving up for a house slowly
and i know it's hard because there's not
a lot of margin right now but that feels
like it's the long-term goal and i'm
hoping that all this craziness is not
forever and so a year from now hopefully
we're looking at a very different
picture and you are work from home and
so that does open you up but i know
you've got to still stay close to home
because of the
situation with your son and so there's
not a ton of options here other than
let's look at the budget let's do a
budget audit where can we save every
single insurance premium every single
expense i'm going through that with a
fine-tooth comb going how can i shave
off 10 bucks 20 bucks 30 bucks yeah
absolutely and then the income i mean
the yeah income and apartment um
situations would change too you know
yeah but you're doing a great job and
you really are you're doing a great job
for where you're at incredible no debt
you have savings i mean all of it you're
you really are but that 60 it oh
that that hurts me it's a tough
situation and this inflation stuff i
mean it's hitting people all over their
pocketbooks from rent to gas to food and
so there's you just batten down the
hatches and let's get to work let's get
the second job if we have to let's trim
the subscriptions that we're not using
right now and all the little luxuries
that we once enjoyed might need to go
away temporarily yeah for a season
because they're saying you know i i read
a report and they think in the next 18
months with just even the
um
the supply chain all of that but i'm
like i mean the hard thing is after two
years i've just learned who knows like
who knows that's right i remember
april of 2020 doing instagram lives i
did one like every other day just to
answer questions and
i remember i said all right guys i think
by august i'll do this
it's all gonna be over
here we are so i'm not predicting
anything but
i think you just have to prepare with
where we're at the reality of what's
going on and what and what sucks is that
that means cutting back some because the
numbers everything is going up yeah and
if you're single you don't have kids
there's more options because we can go
all right let's get you a roommate now
it's more difficult when you have a
family when you've got kids involved
it's not that simple right but if you
work from home that can open you up to a
lot of options too and you may not want
to live on the outskirts of town but for
temporarily for a year if we have to
sign that lease to go all right we can
now breathe and still hit our other
financial goals i'm okay with that and
it's amazing what peace of mind even
does right like we can talk about the
numbers and the percentages and all that
all day long but there is just something
to be said
about when you do have margin it gives
you a level of peace like a level of
like you can take a breath
and sometimes it's worth the things you
never thought you would do i never would
live this far from wherever right people
make these claims
and then when life starts hitting you
and you think okay is it
now i would rather live far farther away
and actually have peace of mind and
margin and enjoy life a little bit more
than everything just getting sucked out
of the paycheck so much out of our
control too and so i always like to go
what is in my control yeah so in
caitlin's situation if i'm anyone
listening right now i'm going all right
let me make a list of ways i can make
more and ways i can spend less i'm gonna
make a list of five things and i'm gonna
go okay which one can i go do this week
this month and just start trying things
what can i sell on facebook marketplace
that's been sitting in the closet for a
while what is that second job i can take
for a few months to just supplement my
income temporarily yeah so if you start
doing all that and that's why i love the
budget audit it's kind of a real nerdy
thing but you go man i'm way overpaying
for auto insurance let me connect with
xander and oh my gosh i just saved 100
bucks right there and you start doing
that in all areas we've talked about
this on your show rachel with cable and
internet and yeah how can we start
shaving all this down our phone bills to
where now we have 200 bucks a month yes
and margin and you can breathe a little
bit yeah and it's not easy i'm not
trying to make it sound like it no but
it's the stuff that's the kind of the
auto the auto draft the auto pay where
you're just like oh and then you look up
two years wow i've never
pushed on that or seen that you know
what i mean and doing that it does it
gives you gives you some more margin
yeah you got to advocate for yourself
and get yourself in a better financial
position and that's why our plan works
in good times and bad i mean imagine if
she had all these debt payments
yeah cool great work caitlin you've done
a great job good job